sponsored by step finance your
go to d5 portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to another episode
of the lehigh plan show so this month we have
a brand new sponsor the crypto exchange bit mech
so a huge shout out to bit max because without bit
max this wouldn't be able to happen so as of may
17th they're actually launching a brand new sport
exchange to easily and instantly buy and sell
crypto so to celebrate they're actually giving
away one million dollars in crypto to spot traders
over the next few months now this is actually the
biggest giveaway in crypto so if you want to
enter then i'm gonna leave the link for you
um in the description below and it's gonna
be really exciting there's a huge range of
different assets that you can easily and instantly
buy so the description um will contain all of the
information and about how to enter into that one
million dollar giveaway that's pretty amazing
so today we are going to have a very interesting
conversation and we are always talking about
controversial things and which we're sort
of not allowed to speak about um but we
have a very interesting person who's going to be
joining me today so joining me is the five-time
world champion ufc mma fighter it is jake shields
jake welcome to the show hey thank you how are
you doing i'm good thanks how are you doing good
like i said uh i slept in woke up trying to get my
[__] together real quick and wake up and do an
interview good well i appreciate you you getting
ready and you being here um because there's
so much that um i want to speak to you about
um you've been very vocal recently despite
coming from you know the mma ufc world
um you've been very vocal about issues that you
see in america so before we delve into that can
you tell everyone a little bit about yourself
for those who don't know who you are from your
mma career to your most recent stance on
free speech government and i guess your
fascination with crypto yeah well it's just
um i mean for me you know originally was a
wrestler through high school in college and then
i got sucked into the mma world through you know
i met um legendary chuck liddell before he was
famous and started training with him and just uh
got completely addicted consumed my life i'm
for sure like you know most people do something
crazy like fighting or a sport and that's all i
wanted to do and just train train train and uh
everyone told me i was crazy but then i seen
chuckled i'll start making money so i'm like
oh i can do it and so luckily uh look i didn't
listen to the haters you know like you said went
out there won five world titles bought you know
in the largest crowd of all time versus george
st pierre had many uh many memorable fights
it's been a great career at this point um
not officially retired but you know i me i may
fight again but mostly just training people and
investing and doing business and uh which is you
know you're in a crypto which is something i need
to get more into i'm mostly invested in stocks
but now might be a good time to hop into crypto
yeah now would be a great time the market is down
now is the best time um but no i think you know
your career has been super interesting um i've
been following and we spoke earlier and i was
mentioning that my brother is a huge ufc fan so
as a child he'd make me watch um so we're going
to delve into all that i do have a lot of them
questions about your career but first i think
what's really struck me is how um you're sort
of now taking on um this weird culture that we
have in america right now um so i guess my first
question really is if why do you feel as a fighter
the need to sort of move the fight in a different
direction and what would you say some of the
biggest problems are for you right now in american
society well a lot of why i started speaking up i
was living in san francisco and stuff was just
getting so weird and i could see it but then i
would i would have conversations with my friends
and people would like yeah i agree with you i just
can't say it because where i work and this and i
just kept hearing over and over people agree with
how i think but they can't say it to me that was
so weird and uh i just never really used twitter
i'd had to twitter for probably like 10 15 years
but like my agents and stuff would maybe tweet out
for me i never used it so i had the password so i
started you know started tweeting out some of my
opinions originally not too good reaction i had a
lot of people were like you know angry unfollowing
me cussing me out i think i started tweeting right
during uh the black lives matter riots and and so
i was like i was against the riots and lockdowns
which are two things that are unpopular now but
at the time the lockdowns and people writing
and luton was extremely popular in america
which is kind of weird so i had a lot of people
angry at me but i'm like you know what i need to
start speaking my mind and just uh slowly did
and then it was crazy i originally had like no
my phone was 100 fighting but now i feel like
it's probably more uh more politics stuff
i get more traction on the political stuff than
the fight stuff i tweet now originally it was like
no traction on the political stuff but then slowly
i had people like um mike cernovich would retweet
me and i'll start picking up a new audience i'll
get like a big you know a big guy like that would
start retweeting you're like oh you're picking up
followers that uh you know i think how i do but
it was really interesting because um when we were
trying earlier you were saying that you were able
to just say what you wanted to say and you didn't
get backlash in your industry compared to other
people for example like artists musicians you know
they secretly feel certain ways and they can't
say it yeah i was extremely fortunate i was unsure
when i started to speak my mind like how are other
fighters gonna feel and then almost almost all of
them were on my side you know even with like uh
even with the black lives matter stuff because
there's really not there's almost zero racism in
fighting we're all brothers on the mats and in the
cage it's one place where you see everyone true
to each other's 100 equals you know we're guys
you might talk [__] to each other but there's
i've never seen racism fighting i'm not
going to say it doesn't exist but it's
it's very small and you notice you didn't
see you know there's a couple fighters that
were black ice matter one or two but it was
not very many no knilling and i respect the
guys that did wear it that we have respect
for each other but i think most of them
realize that it was more of a fake racial divide
than like a real racial divide in our country
and even when it came to the lockdowns
how did the other fighters feel
almost exclusively were against it the first
couple weeks a lot of guys were hiding outside
i was trying to train on the first week i was
calling on my friends and they're like oh we're
quarantining i'm like wait what quarantining what
the hell this i'm not like the smartest person but
i looked at it i'm like we're not going to shut
down for two weeks and the virus is going to go
away when they shut it down it was already in all
50 states you have a virus in all 50 states and
these experts are sitting there telling me that we
can just sit there and it'll go away like you have
to be an idiot not to look at that and be like
this isn't going to happen that's when i realized
i guess a lot of people aren't that smart because
like i said i don't look at myself as a genius but
i could look at that and be like this isn't going
to work so i'm just going to go out there and uh
get covered early and get it over with i just
i find it so fascinating when you told me that
your colleagues and other fighters weren't that
um bothered by what you had to say and in fact
agreed it's sort of because like you know fighting
is all about taking responsibility you're getting
punched all the time like you know you're sort of
used to not living in a sensitive world i guess
yeah i know i said pretty much i was so surprised
all the fighters you too like almost like
almost all of them agree with it it's like
so few and the guys that don't will still
accept we're not kind of we're not industry
we're gonna be like oh you don't agree with
us we hate you like you see on the other
side you know it's not like that but uh
yeah i think it's responsibility and the
reality you know maybe anyone willing to
get locked in a cage with another man in front of
like thousands if not millions of people watching
it's a pretty intense thing to do so maybe
it gives you a different perspective on life
yeah i think i think that's it if you're able to
take a few uh well not a few quite many deadly
punches then i think you can sort of handle um
you know um hateful words which keeps out your
feelings i think things are fighting too like
we get hurt there in the cage but there's also
the amount of stress that goes in there and the
amount of like build up the pressure because it's
not like you're just fighting you might get beat
up you're fighting in front of you know sometimes
millions of people sometimes there's hundreds
of thousands or millions of dollars on the line
if you lose it could be uh there's just a lot
of pressure people learn to deal with i think
in regular life people aren't dealing with those
high pressure situations and i guess fighters once
you get used to that you see the world a little
bit differently yeah i mean you've been in so
many high-profile fights um becoming strike force
champion defending the championship you fought gsp
and the ufc champions so how do you actually deal
with that pressure because you know when you're
the main event and you're the last to walk out how
do you keep calm man it it's tough when you're the
main event if your main event on a big card it's
uh it's stressful ain't gonna lie you have to just
uh you know stay as calm as you can i always
surrounded myself by really good people that i
was comfortable with and laughing people you know
a lot of times before a fight we're sitting there
an hour before we're laughing cracking jokes
30 minutes before we're getting serious ready
to kill but like i would stay relaxed you see
some of these young fighters it's like they're
three hours out from their fight and they're
yelling and screaming and jumping up and down
it's like man you better uh you better save that
energy you're gonna need it oh wow so how do you
how do you deal with it you just sort of have to
only up to the bit where you walk out do you sort
of does that realization happen it's a realization
then yeah i honestly try to like you you'll think
about it at night the scenarios and the fight and
stuff but i was trying to overthink it and like
you know a couple days before i just try to like
bury the fight like hey you know i've done all my
training i'm just not gonna overthink all the bad
things that could happen you know and when you do
picture it picture the good things always picture
yourself winning because you don't want to start
getting in your head well what if this happens
what if he kicks me in the face of this would
this guy has a good flying knee what if what if
he times that right you start thinking about you
have to think about it a little bit of course so
you don't walk into those situations but i think
some guys are over dwelling in all the negatives
and it causes them not to form their fight
there's some fighters that i've you know
trained with who are animals in the gym
they get out there and they just freeze up because
they you know they're overthinking everything
and you actually fought some monsters um both
in strikeforce and ufc like gsp robbie lawler
dan henderson tyrone woodley so who was your
hardest fight um and why and why did they make it
so difficult yeah man i've pretty much fought all
the best guys so it's really hard to say you know
who my hardest fight is had a couple really tough
ones you know damian maya was a tough one because
he's a five-time jitsu world champion and that's
my specialty so we were fighting each other in
our same specialties i think it hit much in that
fight but it was interesting someone who had my
level of jiu-jitsu because he was literally the
only other guy that you know in fighting that had
my level of jitsu so that was interesting overall
pick one probably gsp because he was just um he's
so good at everything he has no holes in his game
he was a true perfectionist and it's like uh you
know i fought him to a close fight but it was just
unable to uh to open up those holes and you know i
think i got a good training camp for that fight i
i wasn't hurt i have no excuses i came in there uh
my best self and he still beat me with a close
decision so he's uh he's an absolute freak you
know there's there's some fights maybe i fought
her or didn't have a good training camp but
that one i trained perfect for went in there and
still came up short something really interesting
that i saw um in the news i think it just came
out actually and the ufc news the other day um
was that you they're banning the flags so you
know when you come out and you have like whatever
country you're from yeah um and i believe that's
something to do with russia do you know more about
this do you have a take on it i don't but i know
one of my uh i think it sucks i think she'll come
with your flags but one of my fighters i trained
an english kid um javid basharat who's actually
he's uh he was born in afghanistan so he wanted
to come out with the afghanistan flag for his
last fight you know i put we got the flag on our
shoulder to walk out like oh you can't walk out
with that flag because taliban's now in charge of
the government and that's not their official flag
but like i know a lot of afghan people and that's
the flag they all they all post that flag no one's
posting the taliban flag so they wouldn't let him
walk out with his flag and i know he was i mean
he took it well but it was it was kind of lame so
maybe it's stuff like that like they don't want uh
you know the people might look at one flag the
government has a different one so it gets a little
complicated personally i think they should allow
it but i think it's something to do with that yeah
i mean like the ufc is supposed to just be about
like getting down to business doing the fights
not caring about political correctness you know if
that's the flag you want to have that's your flag
yeah i agree and uh i don't think dana white's
a good person but he's been great with dealing
political correctness you know that's one thing
even though i don't really like him that much i
think he's i'll give him credit where it's due
like he uh he tried not to stop at all during
the lockdowns which i had mad respect for he
was actually he was going to do a show on um a
native american indian land in california because
they don't uh they don't follow california laws
but our dumb ass governor went uh when called the
head of disney to get it canceled it's like what a
like california doesn't own that land but somehow
in his mind he tried saying like they owned his
land because in california like talk about not
respecting the native american culture oh wow i
didn't know that that's insane yeah because he has
no jurisdiction over the native american indian
land but in his mind he said he did because it
was you know within california limits but it's not
considered california when he went overstepped in
my opinion overstepped his uh his boundaries by by
getting that show cancelled gavin knew some stuff
yeah he said you probably know much about him he's
a terrible governor yes i've heard he likes to
um enforce rules and then not keep them um just
like most politicians um so let let's go let's
go into america um and i guess also just your
fighting background so how important would you say
physical challenges in helping you take on reality
um and the natural struggles that
life will inevitably bring you
first off i think physical activity is absolutely
crucial for every human but men in particular
i think really need to do something physical
and rough i think maybe that's uh maybe that's
part of the decline in america culture you get
these weak men with low testosterone and like um
and weak they have no confidence and they're
weird and they start attacking and trying to
tear everything apart instead of build it up
and that's why fighting and even jujitsu which
is way less intense than fighting the whole jiu
jitsu industry that thinks the same too it's it's
it's not the same you're not getting punched but
you're still getting choked you're getting your
shoulders cranked it's uh that's what i've
been trying to tell people if you have kids
especially boys but but girls too put them in jiu
jitsu it's gonna it's gonna build them character
gonna make them tougher also if they ever need
to if they get a fight you're gonna be able to
win but it just makes you a a better person i
think it's humbling because all of us have had
bad days where there's some dude on your back or
laying on crushing you or choking you and it's uh
it's a very humbling experience to
get choked out and punched in the face
and do you feel like getting choked out and
punched in the face helps you take on other things
in life like if someone's saying being rude or if
someone's you know i don't know whatever people
cry about these days i think it does and the
weird part is for me i was you know getting
a lot of trouble as a kid getting in fights
getting arrested as soon as i started fighting
professionally i didn't do anything anymore i
had no desire to fight someone talked about me i
could just be like i don't care i could beat this
guy up i don't need to prove anything i think the
only times i've gotten a couple couple fights
you got it after i came with pro fighters when
someone insult my friends for some reason that
uh that still really bothers me but it got to the
point where they talked about me i'm like i know
you beat this guy i don't need to prove anything
that makes sense so for you you know you
mentioned blm you mentioned the lockdowns
but what would you say is sort of
the biggest problem for you right now
it's all like complicated everything's kind of
tied together with the you know they have the
it's almost like a bunch you point out it's almost
like a marxism coming in we're trying to like
trying to change what's true and what's not the
weird it's it's all tied in like you know the
whole the whole trans things which i have no
no problem with trans people i actually just
did an interview with um with blair white he
hung out with her she was extremely nice woman
i have no problem calling her a woman but she now
if she went trying to play a woman's sport then i
would call her out and have a problem with it but
she gets it that's wrong she just she prefers you
know being that way so i have no problem someone
wants to do that but to try to tell the reality
of us to tell us that that isn't a man that that's
where it gets weird and and then the worst part is
the shift to doing other kids now which i have a
daughter who went through these schools you know
we're in one of the most liberal places in uh
in america so it's probably her school before
most other places but that you know because she's
a little older now but i remember pushing us
through her school there's pushing this
weird you know you can pick your gender
there's all these like trans kids at schools it's
like they're encouraging it the kids that would
go along with it would get treated better so i
think if you have kids it's very important that
you have like honest critical conversations with
them don't try to pressure that your views are
right but ask them questions make them uh make
them learn to think for themselves otherwise
you know because they're getting bombarded a
good chance they're getting bombarded by their
teachers kids getting told weird stuff like they
can pick their genders and who knows what else
it's so bizarre because like i'm only my i'm only
in my 20s but like so it's not like that long ago
but it's you know still long ago since i was
a child but we never had those conversations
um yeah it's just weird i i don't
know when this sudden shift happened
well here's another weird one there's a fighter
i know if i can say any names but uh yes he has a
daughter in school you know and uh the teacher was
telling her people aren't gonna like you because
you're mexican he was furious he's like why would
you tell my daughter that like i get i get treated
completely normal and you're putting my daughter
head the white people aren't gonna like her and
she's like half white and they're not gonna like
her because of her latinx or whatever the teeth
are trying to say but at least he uh when you know
i think he went chew the teacher out and like you
know don't don't don't fill my kid's head full of
this bs that just perpetuates every like the whole
cycle of problems and poverty by you know teaching
someone victim mentality from such a young age it
100 does and you know like that's what i know is
my daughter's school and luckily my uh you know
my my friend he uh he saw this right away and went
in confronted the teachers once he started talking
to his daughter seeing what they were teaching
unfortunately you know i never went in front of
the teachers i think that was the peak of my fight
career my mind was too lazy to focus on that but
i did talk to my daughter and ask her questions
and see what they're being taught and you know
i would i would have honest conversations and
taught her to critically think and then she'd
go in and challenge the teachers and they would
get mad at her and yell at her and call her stupid
but at least it got her to you know at least she
was confident enough to go and challenge him and
realize there's other ways of thinking that's wild
the closest i came to um that kind of political
indoctrination was um when i was 17 they would
i was in an american politics class and it was
so liberal so left-wing and i wasn't really like
smart enough at the time but there was a guy in
the in class he was like super conservative very
capitalist um and yeah he got kicked out of class
because he kept interrupting he kept saying you're
teaching with a you're teaching with the narrative
yeah a lot of these teachers they don't want to be
challenged at all it's weird because when i was in
school they they didn't i didn't know paul i had
no idea what any of my teachers were i didn't know
what the politics were i didn't know if they were
gay or straight i didn't know there's no reason i
should know this correct but it's changed so
much in such a fast period of time i think um
people are finally starting to see it now
but i don't think stealing the level it's at
and it's weird you know my daughter went to
marin so it probably creeped in that school a
little earlier but it seems like it's creeping
all over the country yeah i think in the uk as
well actually because i was at a dinner a few
weeks ago um and a woman was telling me her
daughter is having these kind of conversations
um but you you mentioned you mentioned um blair
white she's super cool and i i there's two things
you mentioned i want to ask you so number one the
first question is how come you have no problem
calling her a woman because most people don't
yeah i just think because it's respectful to
do because she treated me nice i liked her
and um if you go if you ask me hey is that really
a woman i'm gonna tell you no you know it's not
but i think you'll be disrespectful if if she's
treating me with respect why wouldn't i shoot her
with respect and i would think uh i think
she's great for the community because
all the trans i'd seen on uh online all the trans
activists they made me start to like question and
be like man these trans people are psychopaths
they're like they're defending a guy who's like
jerking off in a girl's bathroom and like playing
women's sports all i was seeing was negative with
trans and that's like the first uh trans person
i hung out with out in austin i'm like oh she's
actually really nice she's smart i can talk to
her to get along so maybe obviously it's still
weird for condition but at least she can see that
she's not trying to say it's like normal and she
gets it and she's a nice nice intelligent person
so okay all trans people aren't bad and they need
they need to put places like her up to get except
to get accepted not the ones they're putting up
they're putting these weird creepy sociopaths the
trans activists instead of someone who's smart
and intelligent like blair yeah i think that's
the point because everybody because you sort of
like aren't allowed to have a conversation about
this because they saw or sort of automatically
think that you know you're inciting violence
and all this stuff which is obviously not true
um and yeah you're right blair is like super
smart intelligent respectful so why would you
want to offend her if she if she says i'd like you
to call me she yeah like sure i don't know i'm not
yeah i'm not going to pretend like it's she was
really a woman but i'm willing to call her a girl
it's like disrespectful not to if she's
respectable to me like it would be it'd
be rude not to so yeah i've no problem calling
her girl as long as she doesn't try the part is
they're trying to make you believe it really is
a girl there's no difference by a biology biology
and clearly you know if she was to fight another
woman now she would have huge advantages well
let's get into that because that was my second
point how do you feel um about yeah trans um
trans women in women's sports so
biological men in women's sports
um i mean it's absolutely ridiculous you're
not gonna give someone estrogen for a year
they're gonna be weaker they might get a little
weaker but it's not gonna be massive i mean
it's it's as you've noticed there's never been a
trans uh what was it a trans man they compete in
women's sports still they don't compete women
in men's sports even though their testosterone
because it doesn't make you know they're too
weak so it just doesn't make sense and i think
um we are seeing some improvement in that because
i remember like a year or so ago when i post stuff
about it i would just get all hate i know a lot of
people believe with me but believe what i said but
no people be afraid to especially girls they'd be
afraid to comment on my post like my post like on
instagram you could just tell they were scared you
know they probably believed they probably see it
and agree with what i said but they wouldn't say
anything but after this swimming incident i would
post stuff and i just saw the tide shift i saw
tons of girls commented on it and uh i think it's
extremely generally you know i'm not a feminist
and i think it's a man's job to fight for a woman
but i think in this particular instance women
are gonna have to stand up for themselves because
what happens when women aren't saying anything
everyone's like well the women don't care why do
you care that's what everyone kept telling me so
it was great to see women finally start to speak
up over this last uh i think the swimming incident
was so absurd they realized wow we really are
going to get all of our sports taken away men are
able to come into our bathrooms and and you know
you know the bathroom one gets it uh gets tricky
because someone like blair probably could use
the woman's bathroom without being a problem but
the problem is you can get a creepy guy that can
just be identified as a woman and come in there
and they will do it there are creepy guys out
there for sure you know there's creepy guys out
there that'll do creepy [__] they get away with
yeah you make so many good
points i mean do you ever
because swimming it's infiltrated swimming right
so and and weightlifting as well as a professional
fighter do you think this will start to infiltrate
um the ufc uh it's already been in pro fighting
there's been two of them that have fought
obviously you know beat girls up but uh the ufc is
gonna be hard because i know dana's not gonna want
it but the ufc is owned by disney disney's huge on
this trans stuff so it gets a little complicated
there might be a power struggle at some point
rather does dana white make the decisions
or do the execs of disney make the decisions
yeah and i think the point you made as
well about women um i'm also not a feminist
um i think it's annoying and it gives me a
headache and i think it's counterproductive
um that's for another for another show um but
but i but i do think you know it is it is a it is
i think a man's job in this world is to protect
women like i think that's what he's on this planet
for um she has other roles he has roles um but
you're right if women don't start speaking up
then we're going to be in a lot of trouble yeah
and i and i think you i don't i think you'd be
great if we didn't have speak up i think it should
be our job to protect them they shouldn't have to
speak up but unfortunately it seems like they
have to in this situation because they were
it's just this is too weird if it's only the
men speaking up it gives the other side to be
like well only men care and clearly most women
agree like almost most people agree with what we
say but they make you think it's the opposite
like remember one time i was talking uh crap
about a fighter uh you know man that beat up a
woman and it's by by far the hardest i've ever
been spammed on twitter you know i had hundreds
of uh of um inboxes telling me to hate me and
thousands of messages telling me how stupid i
was it's a i'm a smart person because i can see
this not the real real world this is just like
hate mobs online or maybe even bots but you can
see if you've never had hate in your life how they
could freak someone out like i've i've been hating
fighting before i've had people throw [__]
at me been booed by thousands of people it's
i can handle a hate mob but if you've never had
a hate mob and you have 10 000 people telling you
kill yourself you're a piece of [__] you're
you're a bigot you can see how people would
get scared and back down and be like okay
maybe i was wrong and not want to fight it
yeah it gets brutal out there um it gets really
really aggressive um but no i i i think that it's
definitely a strange situation to be in um and do
you do you think there's any point whereby like
hormones could really equalize the playing field
um not that they have now maybe they could have
been something but i don't think there's no way to
do it and it's um yeah it's unfortunate you know
if trans can't compete in sports but it just might
be the reality of it you can't take for a small
tiny bit of population and kill women's sports
or they can go you know if you're trans women
you compete in men's sports or you can get a trans
league and yeah it sucks for them but they're just
not a large enough percentage of population to
completely screw over women you know it's uh you
know it's just not fair to completely destroy
their sports and it's a it's an athlete i think
that one you know i take it seriously because i
know how much work we put into sports and i do
think less women put the kind of work in sports
men's do but but the ones at the top they do
they do sacrifice their whole life trying to
make it to the top and if you have these girls
they're just grinding grind trying to win
a national champ and someone comes in there
switches over you know from a man to a woman and
goes and takes their title away that they've spent
you know in some cases 15 years struggling to win
it's just uh that one really gets me because i can
relate being an athlete i guess it's funny because
it's not the other way around right but you sort
of mentioned this earlier so is it doesn't that
just sort of like prove the point it completely
does but there's quiet on it and the trans men
they actually compete against women because they
know they can't stand a chance against men and
they allow them to take steroids so they get
to go in there on steroids because they're
trans so they can they can break the rules
it's completely unfair and stupid has there been a
trans man by so a biological woman that has beaten
a man a biological man in any sport or fighting
definitely uh i don't think it's too likely i mean
they'll be one-offs i'm sure there's some girls
that you know could be some guys in some sports
but a girl's never gonna uh a girl is never
gonna be the top guy that's the whole debate
you know i remember like rhonda rousey's amazing
but there was one point where joe rogan's like oh
i think she'd take some of the men in the
ufc it's like come on joe i love you but
if you really think a woman's gonna be the top
fighter yeah she's gonna beat up an average dude
for sure on the streets but not a professional
fighter yeah no that makes sense i think it's
funny because um i don't really believe in
the patriarchy as such but like if there was
a patriarchy like this is the patriarchy it's
like men taking over women's swords no it is and
that's that part of me wants to just laugh it's
not being a feminist it's like oh men win again
we're taking your sports we're taking your locker
rooms part of it's like funny and i want to just
laugh but then you look at it it's like you know
it's disgusting i have a daughter it's like uh
it's you know it's just not fair there's well you
know men and women are different there's no reason
why we shouldn't have separate spaces you know i
like it when i go to the gym and it's all men and
we can you know have camaraderie and get along and
maybe that's part of the reason why fighters uh
think one way because we go and big groups of men
and we hang out we talk crap to each other we beat
each other up and we have like uh a group people
you can relate to i think women need that too
yeah well women women we can't
do that we're not built that way
basically unfortunately that's
the reality of it i much prefer
the way the men do it it's better um but
yeah okay speaking of that locker room style
and talk and things like that um freedom of
speech is massively um under attack and um
elon musk sort of seems like he's here to save
the day so i'd like to get your thoughts on elon
musk um acquiring twitter do you think this
is actually going to improve the whole sphere
i think it will you know it's you never know what
his real motives are but he seems he seems pretty
genuine i think he really cares about free speech
i mean he's a guy who too i think a year or two
ago started kind of putting his real thoughts out
there he was the guy i never knew anything about
and i think the i think the lockdown sort of got
to him he started slowly putting little things out
like this sucks and now he's like he's one of the
best people on twitter he fully puts on i'm sure
he has a whole self out there but he puts on all
kinds of interesting intriguing tweets that uh
none other billionaires are doing he
puts a little personality out there
and shows he cares about free speech and he was
anti-lockdown which is uh which is huge you know
and stuff stuff like that and i'm sure i don't
agree with everything but he seems like uh
he's one of the more interesting men of our
entire generation i mean he gets hate a lot
but the guy you know revolutionized you know
banking with paypal uh electric cars with tesla
which you know i'm not even from environment but i
have a tesla because they're amazing cars like you
know people hate on it but you drive those things
like you don't even really want to drive the cars
after that it's like they're so quick i can put
self-driving on let my car drive itself it's like
he makes he makes a good [__] car people can
hate on it because it's electric but you think
the left's like i'm unsure if electric cars are
better for the environment but that's what the
left's saying and then they hate the guy who does
that you know and he's revolutionized rocket ships
and now hopefully he's uh he's defending free
speech i'm pretty sure he's sincere i know a
lot of people say he's not but i think he's
sincere with wanting to protect free speech
yeah i do agree i think he's also sincere
um but speaking of that that hypocrisy
um did you see um the tweet that he did where
um bill gates asked if he would invest in his
philanthropy or whatever and he was like but
you still have a really big short position on
tesla anyway i didn't see that tweet but that's
it but i heard him mention something about how
he heard that uh he had a huge short against
them it's uh yeah yeah they're really trying to
short the company that would save the environment
they're saying they're environmentalists it's uh
i think i mean i actually had a lot of friends
that shorts against tesla because they didn't
they thought he was over hyping it and it was
going to collapse and to be fair it was you know
there was one point where the company could have
collapsed but i just uh you know i didn't have
one at that point but i drove the cars and i'm
like man this company's gonna come through this
guy makes too good of cars but it is possible
to make a great product and uh and still fell
but like luckily elon musk managed to push through
and they're i think the most uh things are the
biggest car company in the world now yeah i mean
i'm also not that like big and crazy on fixing the
environment or whatever i don't know but the cars
are amazing the the screen and the way you can see
the people walking wow you know he just makes a
good a good car you can't deny that you know if
i had other expensive cars but the tesla drives it
dries up with it it can compete with cars that are
way more expensive that's my opinion yeah there
may be like you know some some elite elite cars
might not drive them but they're gonna be way
more expensive way more expensive to maintain
saying too once you get a tesla there's zero
money to maintain it zero gas it just drives
so are there just back to elon musk and
free speech and stuff like that are there
um any accounts that you think are gonna come back
like do you think donald trump will be reinstated
i think he will if he comes back because he has
his own um true social which is stupid because
these niche ones just don't work no one wants to
or some people want to i don't want to go in a
circle jerk where everyone thinks exactly the
same that's why i went on gab or one of those
for a second i'm like it's all it is is everyone
thinks exactly the same i like following liberal
accounts and seeing how i like seeing other people
think i don't i'm not trying to put myself in a
in a little like easy box where everyone says the
exact same thing and that's what truth social is
going to be it's funny we're probably not some
little liberal ones start up that are huge for uh
huge censorship this is going to be you know
they won't get big though that's why they'll
ban themselves into like non-existence and that's
what elon everyone kept telling elon to start a
new show a new one but he realized it was too late
twitter has become the place and you can't you
can't change that now so even though even when i
hated twitter i never threatened to leave because
i knew that was where the dialogue happens and it
is people aren't on twitter they don't realize how
um impactful it is they're like oh most people
aren't on there but it's where all the news is
shaped all the information is put out there first
is where people are fact checked when they try
lying people on twitter will go out there and see
you know you get the only place you can see the
truth and that's why they're so scared of the elon
buying it because they want to be able to control
what we see and what we don't so on that
point because you did tweet about that
actually you tweeted saying that the elites
are freaking out over elon buying twitter
um i agree and i think many work celebrities um
are threatened that their accounts are get an er
um go or they're threatening to lose their own
delete their own accounts i think actually some
british ones have actually left to it already
um but say that again sorry but they'll be back
they'll be back yeah yeah yeah exactly um but what
okay so why do you think then it was celebrated
when jeff bezos bought the washington post it was
like celebrated as this huge cultural innovation
this huge cultural shift and then elon musk
wants to buy twitter and everyone's crying
well because jeff bezos is going to play along
with the narrative and they know that and elon
musk might not and it's like uh they they could
always censor through the mainstream media what we
saw before and it's like you know everyone talks
about oh how about how fake the media has became
maybe they've always been that fake and we just
couldn't tell if you didn't have twitter to fact
check them i mean there's there's so much stuff
throughout history that who knows they've been
lying to us all along you know you see things like
you know they convinced us that iraq had weapons
of mass destruction and pushed us into that war
with twitter people probably fact checked it and
seeing that that was you know fake statistics
and uh you know doc fauci has a lot of time any
doctors that disagree with his age theory he was
pushed off he gets him pulled off tv there was
nowadays they could go on twitter and say their
theory because a lot of people don't think fauci's
aid theory is correct which it is a little weird
you know straight people aren't out catching aids
yeah you tweeted about that um can you go
into that in a bit more detail because i
think i'm like i'm a bit too young to know
what happened i don't know the exact all the
details but i just know it doesn't smash past
the smell test because when i was a kid they
pushed non-stop fear for out having sex with
condoms we're all going to catch aids and um
you know the way colleges are nightlife scene
people have a lot of unprotected sex aids would
be everywhere but for whatever reason aids only
passed between gay people and uh intravenous
needle users if you ask someone to name a straight
person with aids the only person they'll say is
magic johnson but then he never got sick he never
crossed over and got sick from aids he never
he's still healthy so if you can name one straight
person in the entire world that's uh that's a
little bit strange to me when they're telling
us you catch it this way now they do have aids
in africa but it has different characteristics
and it but africa is extremely dirty place dirty
sewage there's a lot going on so it's hard to say
uh what it is but you don't realize aids is simply
it's when your immune system attacks itself and
you start having a lower immune system it's not
necessarily one disorder there could be different
ways people are getting it and you know i i don't
know the exact answer what it is but clearly we
should put some research on it and there is some
major you know doctors that disagree with voucher
but they just get pushed out and they're scared to
question them i know there are theories out
there i just personally don't know what they are
you tweeted something about um your cousin
if you don't mind me bringing that up
you said that he had aids he was doing fine and
then he took a drug that felt she was pushing yeah
man that was terrible because when i was a little
kid and that was the time too fauci was saying
like you know maybe you can get aids being close
contacts i was close to my cousin but then i would
get scared being around them and he was doing
okay with aids and they put him on the stuff azt
and as soon as he went on it he just you know
got sick it's like he's a chemo drug he started
getting sick and then died within a couple months
it seemed to just uh put him out i was recently
doing some reading on azd and a lot of people
think that's actually what the biggest cause the
deaths were in aids because there was hardly any
aids deaths dr fauci pushed azt started pushing
out in the public aids deaths spiked ass actu
spiked then all of a sudden they realized they
were giving people weight way too much azt they
cut it way way down and then the deaths of hiv
dropped down to almost nothing now you're hardly
sure about people dying of aids wow so a lot of
people think that actually the biggest part of the
aids epidemic was fauci killing people with azt
that's insane like i don't know about this i
didn't either what was this like it was like the
late 80s and 90s and i didn't either but i
remember like when fauci first took over the
thing like oh seems like a nice guy my friend
john joseph of crowmax was ranting about what
a sociopath evil guy this is and i'm like
huh it's interesting john thinks this album
but after recently going back and going back and
looking and seeing all the stuff you do you're
like wow this guy really is uh really is a bad guy
and uh you know all the ties to the drug companies
he has and all that he controls i believe 100
of the funding for infectious disease so he can
control what gets uh studied and what doesn't so
you can't like study any any other theories than
what he tells you to so the question then is is
this is is this driven by money is this driven
by some people talk about depopulation what do
you think yeah i see i i don't really know my
guess would be money in power but sometimes it's
hard to so many people just seem so evil you try
being like why do you need more money like why
are you doing this stuff like you know why are you
why are you torturing puppies but getting them
eaten up by flies like can you explain that well
that to me as well because you tweeted that before
you went live and i didn't have time to like be
like what is this talking about they did this
weird experiment on these flies that they might
have some kind of flesh eating thing and they put
them on these puppies and let them like slowly
eat them alive why they and some of them lasted
up to like 100 like 90 something days that they
tortured them until they totally died of just
like eating beef little cute beagle puppies too
it's like why'd they do that they were trying to
see what what kind of effect the flies would have
on the skin or something i don't know i'd have
to do with exact study but it was they have they
have a reason they're going to argue they're
testing something but that's we don't wait
yeah you shouldn't test something by torturing
puppies yeah it's just it's just so crazy um
it's very strange um but you you were recently
on joe rogan um it's not gone live yet am i right
it's not it went out it went out a couple weeks
ago he was on the mma show because he has the mma
show and the um and the regular podcast because
i was looking for it yeah so i think they kind of
separate the mma and the um and uh we talked like
half politics half of may but you know when most
the fighters obviously go on mma show okay well
i'll i'll i'll check it out so tell me how was
that it's pretty cool it's kind of weird because
it's like three hours that's a long time to talk
and you're kind of sitting there and you're like
um after three hours you kind of you know i i
didn't have a watch never clocks completely lost
track of time so you weren't really sure and then
he kind of stops the show and you're like you
walk out and you're like damn what do we just
talk about knowing there's probably millions of
people listening you're like well i hope it wasn't
too stupid but uh luckily i've only gotten good
feedback i'm sure there's a few haters are like
you suck but overall i was like oh you did really
good so it's uh you know it's definitely not like
nerve-wracking but it's a little weird you're
saying they're just chatting back and forth but
joe makes you comfortable he's a guy i've known
for years so it wasn't uh it wasn't too weird
getting on him and like i said we're fighting you
do you don't think about like oh building people
to watch me fight don't think about like oh like
10 million people might watch this interview you
just kind of yeah want to relax and [__] and
joe you know he's a funny guy so we were kind of
our conversation uh flowed the whole time you
know he's a great conversationalist because
three hours the conversation never stopped that's
uh that's pretty impressive to be able to do that
let me think it's just impressive to be able to go
on anyway and be able to talk for three hours um
you said you spoke about politics and fighting
what did you talk about when it came to politics
ah man we were kind of all over the place we
didn't get into any like really big details
any little elon musk and to be honest
i haven't rewatched it and i can like
i can hardly even i remember it people were
telling me like oh you talked about this and
i'll be like oh yeah kinda but it gets weird
uh watch myself give interviews i'll probably
overthink things so i'm like i'm just not
gonna watch it i'm too too critical of myself
yeah i could i can imagine um but no i i
definitely need to need to check that out
so in terms of just like fighting aside but just
you know talking about everything that's going
on in the world um how driven are you like how
um like how far do you want to go are you just
gonna like tweet about it talk about it like what
are your what are your plans i mean i have no set
question set plans right now you know ultimately
i try to you know look i think the best thing you
can do is look out for yourself make sure you're
just saying yourself make sure you're making money
for yourself your family around you and uh take
care of yourself first but it is nice to try to
help people you know the first things uh twitter
i mean i have thought about politics but then you
start looking into it you're like man this is
a mess do i really want to get involved in this
yeah yeah it's it's a hard one um i think it was
i think jordan peterson was sort of talking about
the shift in his life um you know he was just a
normal man and then suddenly he's sort of like
the most loved and hated person
simultaneously um but humanity needs him
yeah i know it's weird i think it's it's uh a lot
of times i pick your mind people like you more
and people will hate you more so you if you can
deal with that go ahead to me it doesn't bother
me being hated so i don't really care i mean i
have all my friends and and whatnot something that
cracks me up is all the time people will like dm
me or ask on a post like what does uh what is the
one of you i guess pretty famous friends like
what is nate or what does chuck think of your
opinions and it's like dude they're my friends
do you really think they're going on my twitter
i mean they might read my twitter but you really
think they're look at this and get mad at me
we like we're like brothers we've been friends
forever we we obviously agree on a lot of stuff
but if we happen to post something they don't
agree with sounds like we're not going to be
friends and some of these people i feel bad
for them if you have a friend that want to be
your friend because something you post on twitter
unfortunately it's like it's like that some places
these these liberal places you post the wrong
stuff i mean conservatives do it a little bit but
at the moment it's definitely uh liberals that
are pushing for the craziness you know i never
consider myself a conservative but i get lumped
in you know by being pro free speech you know
anti-lock downs i mean i do like lower taxes that
type of stuff you get considered like far right
yeah i mean i'm i'm actually um one of those
people unfortunately that just like lost a ton
of friends um because of all of this like um
like i just don't i just don't align with the
whole feminist narrative um i just think it's
like self-hating um to be honest um and really
counterproductive um and all my friends were like
crazy about the lockdown like i had a friend who i
went for a walk with her in 2020 the beginning
of the pandemic in the park and she like was
like miles away from me jesus and i was and i was
just like whatever you know like i went home and i
was sort of like telling my family about it and i
was just like whatever you know it's good to have
friends and people around you um so i never cut
them off but they cut me off in the end because
they couldn't take my views yeah i mean just
sometimes it's just people grow apart and that's
reality they can't take who you are but this is
who you are i think you're gonna be a lot happier
speaking your mind and uh and making real friends
and trying to be fake and you know i just noticed
i had friends that were like that who you know
their friends were all the way but they didn't
believe that way and they're trying to trying to
fake it and get along and fit in with them and
it's it's tough it's like do you really want
to pretend like you agree with these people
but that's how hateful they are if you don't
they're going to try to cut you out and that's
that's to me like i do have friends that are
liberal i have no problem with it people that
you know i like having debates hearing my friends
opinions and why that's when you have real friends
but people that get get weird and they can't have
friends other opinions it's uh it's on them it's
on them um okay so just last topic um you dm
me about crypto have you bought any crypto yet
a tiny bit of like bitcoin ethereum but but not
much i need it's down now so now it's probably a
good time to start buying it so yeah it's tragic
we're at we're at 30.8 right now i'm like oh i'm
watching while i when i'm oh wow maybe i'll go
buy some right after we get off this that's that's
you never know what it's going to do but it
seems like the stock market's down too it's uh
inflation's high it's definitely not a good time
for uh for anything real estate the interest rates
are going up so houston's probably gonna come down
so it's like uh where do you put your money if you
hold it in cash it's losing value and the stock
market bitcoin is not doing great so it's a it's
a tough time but i think uh like i said most more
money is like in stocks now i think it would make
sense to put some of it in crypto in your opinion
do you just do bitcoin or you do anything else
um okay so i get called like a bitcoin maximalist
which basically means i think bitcoin is the
best but i'm not a bitcoin maximalist by some
definition so i think that bitcoin is the ultimate
store of value despite the fact that it's down i
think long term it is the ultimate store of value
i think it's the best form of money that there is
um i think everything else is quite interesting
and so i do invest in other things um but i'm also
very very aware of the fact that they are projects
they are centralized and they are startups and
so that's why i don't really promote very much
about the other coins that i buy as an example i
hold solana right like i don't really talk about
this too much um i hold solana um and um but
solana is very centralized it's very vc funded
um and the network gets turned on and off again so
like i wouldn't actively like tell people to buy
solana because it's just a gamble and it's not
good money you know yeah yeah i bought a little
dogecoin real quick and made some money real quick
but but i bought it knowing it was stupid i just
saw elon musk tweeted about it real quick like oh
i'm gonna go buy some of that real quick and then
it shot up shot of almost 100 times unfortunately
i didn't sell it at the top but still you know
it went up so much that obviously i was gonna make
some money yeah that's amazing that's good um you
need to you need to get in um you need to know
where you can be getting your good interest rates
you need to know how to take self-custody do you
know about that yet self-custody no what's that so
it's essentially keeping your money um so when you
leave your money in the bank you don't actually
own it like they can freeze your funds right like
we saw in canada actually it's like they did in
canada yeah that was kind of a wake-up call like
man i need to i need to actually buy bitcoin not
buy bitcoin through like these apps well that's
the point so like the ceo of um i think it was
kraken which is another exchange he told his he
told his um customers who were based in canada
he said if if it comes down to it we will legally
have to freeze your funds so withdraw your money
so where do you withdraw it you take it um and you
take self-custody and you move it off the exchange
and you hold it directly just you and the
blockchain that's it no intermediary just you and
the blockchain so nobody can freeze your funds yes
so that's the really exciting part yeah i think
that to me is the most intriguing thing about
bitcoin especially because what happened in canada
we've never seen that you know in modern times and
the western government sees money but the fact of
canada would do it we're not much different i mean
biden would happily do anything that should always
do might be a little harder in the us but they
can do it there it's reality they could do it here
yeah exactly and um yeah basically but the thing
with bitcoin is if it's sitting on an exchange
it can be taken yeah they can't freeze it yeah
so at least you have like so if they freeze your
freezer bank account you still have money in
the bitcoin so you still have no i'm saying you
they can no i'm saying they can they can't use
your bitcoin if it's on an exchange if it's on
exchange exactly but if you have the what
your own keys which which is what i need to
do because i don't have that yet so right now i
don't really have bitcoin okay well we'll teach
you how to do that another time but yeah it's just
so amazing and i think what's so interesting is
would you say canada was like a real wake-up
moment for you then when it came to bitcoin
with the bitcoin yeah you know i already thought
it was interesting and you know i wanted to get
some but seeing that it's like oh shoot i i really
better buy some you know my accounts i have the
wrong opinions my accounts could get shut down and
all of a sudden you have no freedom you shut your
bank account you can't you know you can't drive
you can't eat you can't you can't do anything
do you know about central bank digital currencies
is that the one the governments are trying to make
or uh yeah i've heard a little bit about it but
don't know a lot yeah i think i feel like they
want to go to track every dollar they want to
know uh what you spend you can't cheat taxes
that way they want to see where your money's
going they can shut your money off if they
want i think that's the future they want but
hopefully the people push back and resist it
yeah there you go you're super clued up when it
comes to crypto you know what you're talking about
you got it i know a little bit a lot of friends
are in it luckily uh i had friends that were in
it early they were getting it for like a couple
hundred dollars yeah wow obviously didn't sell
at the top but that's the friends made pretty good
money on bitcoin it's like man i wish i would have
been buying it then yeah well despite the fact
that it's down like i always say this i i think
bitcoin's going to a million i don't know when
maybe 10 years 15 years um i'd say 500 000 in the
next five years don't quote me but i'm comfortable
to say that because i think i think it's happening
um and yeah central bank digital currencies are
insane they're just programmable money so like
if you don't have your vaccine or whatever it
is then you know you may not be able to go spend
you may not be able to buy certain things like i
think it was in canada you weren't allowed into
um certain um supermarkets unchaperoned um to
make sure that you were only buying essential
items so you were buying let's just say like
food as opposed to i don't know toys or whatever
yeah i think australia too right so
with a central bank digital currency
you don't need the chaperone it just becomes a far
more uh efficient way to discriminate basically
yeah and i definitely see him doing this you know
i i spent i i was 20 years in san francisco and
they made it so i couldn't go in a restaurant
couldn't i mean like i moved out of there but
when i visited i couldn't even go to restaurant
couldn't go into bar i mean people left me in
bars because people know me and didn't ask me for
a thing and i could go restaurants people went to
ask but technically they weren't supposed to let
me in anywhere luckily there was a few good people
that you know weren't forcing the rules but it's
just that's absurd the city passed the past and
you know majority people were happy to go along
with like let's cut the unvaccinated people out of
society it's like they tried to come back outside
a year ago and i think we're just gonna forget
yeah i'm not forgetting i'm like i'm not
forgetting at all um so you so you spent a lot
of time in san francisco so many years have you
officially left yeah i'm in las vegas now i had uh
during the lockdowns they were just so extreme
i'm like i gotta get out of here city was getting
you see everything a liberal city doesn't want
to do they did wrong just the homelessness the
dirtiness the drug addicts over the streets the
crime rate spiking lockdowns for a year the gym
i was running you know we got close close down for
a year people could go to the gym you know we were
there working out illegally but how are you gonna
stay in business when you still have rent to pay
and you don't have money coming in and you know
we're not gonna charge people when they're not
working out so it's uh i was thankful that you
know i knew all the gym owners i don't know what
i've done if i couldn't work out i had like uh at
that point all my work i was doing was shut down
i had nothing to do to sit around the house and
i'm not uh to me that's not mentally healthy to
sit around do nothing i had to go and work out and
go and do stuff and uh but luckily i was able to
find people pretty quick that were willing to go
to jitsu with me jiu jitsu is probably the worst
thing you could do according to the kogan rules
but hey i never got sick the last couple years
that is i keep knocking this mic um that is that
is wild um i was at a party actually the other
day and i met a girl from san francisco and just
given i'm like heavily living on twitter in the
metaphors um you know i hear people complaining
all the time about san francisco so i said to
her i was like oh i hear san francisco so bad
and she's like no it's not and i was like oh i
heard there's homeless everywhere and she's like
no it's not that's just what the conservatives
are saying to make you think that it's and i was
like well i've never been so i don't really know
i mean things have to go there are some areas
that are like not as bad but the homelessness
drug ass usually push into a small area and that
area keeps expanding and expanding so pretty much
taking over the whole the whole downtown area now
there are areas in san francisco you can go where
they're not there and the same thing with the
crime too though used to be you know they'd get
you certain spots but now they're going through
residential neighborhoods stealing your cars home
invasions robberies it's just getting uh more
and more lava lawless the d.a there won't really
prosecute crime i mean he's so extreme though even
san francisco is recalling him because his parents
are actually were in prison for killing three
cops so this guy hated police and then somehow
he's the one in charge of putting people in jail
wow yeah i heard this someone was telling me that
you're not that you that you could steal up to
like a certain amount of money and then they're
not going to come after you that's i think it's
all california that's 9.50 so they can't arrest
you if you steal less than 950 so the cops won't
come so they break in their car that's how point
you come if you call them so they don't think
it doesn't matter yeah they can come up to you
and you can just tell the cop to [__] off and
keep walking away makes no sense these laws wow
okay all right so i won't be won't be moving to
california i'll be staying comfortable here in
florida yeah florida seems like one of the ones
florida texas a few free states a lot of the
states they talk about too you know like arizona
montana these places are extremely free they just
kind of fly under the radar yeah probably for
the best um so nobody comes knocking they'll
change anything exactly montana don't want people
coming oh really that's funny i'll have to i have
to look into that um okay so do you have any um
anything that like you're working on right now
um or like how can people follow you find you and
keep updating everything you're doing yeah twitter
jake shows aj there's jake shields on instagram as
far as stuff pushing and there's not really much
they need to have a clothing line i launched
uh american jitsu which is american fight.com
you know people that are interested in fighting
i have some dvds on bga fanatics but most of my
stuff i'm doing is uh i don't really need promo
for amazing well guys please go follow jake
um he's talking about things that really
matter right now um not enough people
um are brave enough to speak up about it so head
over to um his twitter if you're not following
him already jake thank you so much for coming
on it's been so fascinating speaking with you
um and yeah i want to thank you so much great
yeah thanks for having me i'm sure uh we'll stay
in touch and i'll see you at some point so have a
good day absolutely all right guys thanks so much
for watching don't forget to tune in for another
episode next week and we will see you all then
the layout show